cs go is home to
plenty of legendary players you've got
your aim gods you've got your edge shut
machines
and you've got your 200 iq geniuses
but one set of players stands above the
rest
the clutch masters oh he's got to jump
does he go higher does he go low ground
that's not short there we go the jump
comes in but how do you defuse the bomb
oh he's got a cover for it
snacks you've got to be fast you got to
be fast put it back again
these are the guys you want on your side
when the pressure is
on whether it's a 1v2 or a 1v5
csgo's greatest clutch gods will face
down impossible odds
and annihilate the competition every
time
these are the top 10 most clutch players
in cs go
kicking off our list is one of csgo's
most
iconic clutch gods kiko it will once
again just be hiko
is he about to pull off the alamo he's
got three from behind quad can he find a
fourth
he gets the fourth he's on for the eight
so he gets
what now hikosius go career may have
ended with his entrance into valorant
denying us any more cs clutches in the
future
but back in his glory days in a 1vx
situation
there is no one else you'd rather have
to single-handedly put the team on their
back
and clutch out round after round that
bomb plant's already been happening for
quite a while here so hiko
and sean has a good kill for hika but
they realize the priest still in there
somewhere they're gonna try and go for
it here they want to go all in eco comes
in
with another kill and back to a two on
two that bomb so far take they gotta
move quick right now
they're going for it the defuse is
already happening hey girl you're
kidding me
he's gonna go for it they win the round
he go fix up a triple a cloud nine win
it what
coming in at the number nine spot on our
list is guardian and
all the times he said nope not today
and just the pistols to play with they
needed the kill guardians got to make up
for it he's tapping him but he can't
find it fallen's on the defuse
fallen is on the defuse the lineup
he doesn't have the ammo he doesn't have
the ammo he's holding
guardian between his time on faze clan
and navi
guardian's name has become synonymous
with clutch play at big events and grand
finals
guardian just has this magic superpower
to turn
hopeless situations into godlike wins
when it's crunch time and the map is on
the line
you can bet your ass guardian is gonna
save the day
this is a done round guardian now as
question as to whether he'll save the
awp good flashbang
could get a couple more out of this one
and fanatic are starting to crumble
what's going on
one player has found three kills
guardian
looking to ace this one out this could
be one of the best rounds of the entire
tournament so far
four kills picked up it's down the
crimped this was a five versus one map
how does he work back in it's gone
toward the dumpster that means guardian
knows exactly where to load
he's got all five
number eight goes to one of counter
strike's most
legendary players and we wouldn't have
had it any other way
it's france's op god kenny s
forrest gets caught that's gonna end the
play a little bit for an ip but that
kill coming back to nbk opens up the
plant potential watch can he drop down
hits exist up close and it's kept right
versus kenny what a tantalizing 1v1 spot
enough oh
that is unbelievable when you think of
kenny s you think of sick flicks
you think of no scopes you think of
iconic plays he gonna try and go huge
here
kenny s on site straight in his face
doesn't hit the nose go
doesn't hit the pistol
[Applause]
would you believe it the balls on that
man to go for that play
but over the years an underrated part of
the frenchman's game
has been his ability to clutch out a
round whether it's a dire post-plant
situation
or a near impossible retake kenny can do
it all
and he can do it with style kenny you
know one versus three and luminosity
they are one round away
from match and matt point here kenny
getting a single headshot he's got the
double
sprays gets one more there's no goddamn
way that he's gonna do this
he's got no health calls gonna go for it
he gets the shot kenny what are you
doing
you've got to be kidding at the clutch
oh my god
coming in at number seven is a four-time
major champion
15-time mvp and the best-looking man on
the server
you guessed it it's device and on top of
all of those incredible titles he does
have one more
clutch god as device in another one
versus three
this time doesn't have the freedom of
movement toward pitt even if she should
find the first pick because they cover
off apartments
it's olaf inside and the movement
finds the first jw goes down he still
has a chance they want to walk out from
apartments
both close finds one drops back down and
he's got it as well
olof's head torn off a device takes one
out of the pages of zip x
to pull it 16-16 but of all the clutches
tom cruise has achieved in his career
there really is
none better than this disgusting pistol
clutch he pulled on nrg
at the star ladder berlin major
currently no kid has been picked up they
need to find a way to get these kills
and get on that bomb very quickly
and now it's all fall in the problem oh
my god
that can't possibly be real
flusha's career has been a long and
eventful one
as one of the few remaining old guards
of cs go
this swedish legend holds some of the
best clutches ever seen
some so sick he's even been called a
cheater
i think the most annoying player to play
against in clutch equation is flusha
which is something about how he moves
and how he plays that's just so freaking
annoying i don't know why
could spot out guardian but the cavalry
has arrived flamie is already on the
site and while caesar's rotated around
how does flusha find him in the smoke
like that
the hell is going on six seconds five
seconds
now it's all on seize he's gonna use
that instead area to force him out into
the open and flush out with the clutch
how does that happen quad kill clutch
from flusha
but what's truly impressive about flusha
is that nearly all of his clutches start
with nearly unwinnable scenarios
no matter how hard the clutch might be
flusha's
vac-like aim and giant brain make it
look
all too easy definitely spots him oh
not only does he spot him thank you very
much oh wow
no way no way
and not only that he's caused a full
rotation from ivy from rain and sort of
zika inside of z connector flusha gets
one more kill on this lycra's got the
whole map to play with
he's hoping that flusha can anchor this
position down but he has the option to
go back to a look at flusha go my god
this would be a harsh reset on 14 rounds
for fnatic
and that smoke is tantalizing
flusha he's going to clean out connector
and he could actually spoil the whole
plan as sneaky as flusha wanted
oh my god that is one of the most
impressive clutches you will ever see
taking our number five
spot is the hungriest man in cs go
snacks there you have it you've got what
two or three players coming through
and wait what is this no way
snatched
back in his heyday snacks was one of the
scariest players on the server not just
because he was a mechanical
god but because of his obscene clutch
factor
and it's going to be bialy down in the
end to just snacks
does find one let's not leave him out of
this the big apple and snacks is hungry
he's got one kill already on the usp
low hp as well on guardian and flame
he's trying to bait them out trying to
get them into one on ones as he dances
back and forth between the box what a
shot on simple
oh guardian bye-bye and it's on the
flamey he's tapped it flame he's got a
big
what in god's name is
fallen comes in at number four on our
list thanks to his undeniable talent
200 iq plays and of course his
truly ridiculous ability to clutch he's
playing close to it
they're gonna put one man through
tunnels in breeze so it's one player per
position and fallen kicks in the door
takes the second oh he knows he knows
exactly where brees is at breeze
crossing over the site
fallen this would be a huge clutch to
keep mibr doubled up on the score but
he's gets
smoked and he's inside of it the bombs
ticking
way too quick for brees to even clutch
this fallen
you big brain beauty there's no doubt
that fallen will
go down as one of the best igls ever to
touch the game
from 2016 to 2017 he led csgo's most
dominant team taking back to back major
titles
and winning just about everything so
when it came to seeing and understanding
the game
fallen was second to none and he made
clutching rounds
seem easy you're a bit of a believer
would you suggest that you
don't want to stop believing why don't
you cast the round
okay tack's up one he's gonna get bro
i'm starting to believe as well henry
because he's gonna take inflation
stop blowing my mind this is gonna be
absolute madness
a round that we will forget because
there goes zeus saving the day for nafi
but could you
stop he's actually got away with it zeus
is out of the round
no way oh my god has done this
i thought zeus had time but no
luminosity i told you
you've just got to believe sometimes
alex
i think we can all agree that coldzera
is an absolute
monster when it comes to cs go whether
it's his ridiculous aim or
crazy sixth sense this brazilian legend
can do it all
and that's why he's coming in at number
three on our list
well he has low health but he does still
have the ak cold with everything to do
just popping noggins
he's cleared three bodies and the fourth
i didn't i didn't think it was actually
gonna
i didn't think he would actually do it
unlike fallen
cold wasn't known for his genius game
sense he was known for his aim and raw
skill
but cold always shines on the biggest
stages
dennis is spamming up through the bench
leaving coldzera in a one-on-four
there's the first looking for a snack
and he connects it
oh and he gets a third as well surely
he's not gonna pull this one
off caldera the man the myth the beast
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
one of the first
ever clutch gods we're talking about the
og
clutch master the guy who was clutching
while some of these other guys were
still in digital diapers
it's france's very own shaksi
it's on shots in a 103 to try and keep
it alive otherwise we'll go to a fifth
map in the grand finals
shocks tabs out one that's a deadly kill
goes for the second
and he's moving closer looking for the
quad clutch here fnx the last man alive
he's going to tap the bomb once
you've got to be kidding he takes the
quad kill throughout his career
shocks has been one of the clutches
players in the cs go world
accumulating a total of 675
1vx all-time clutches but the numbers
don't tell the whole story
it's all on shocks he picks up one and
goes back for more he has no grenades
luminosity in overtime you're looking
for the shot shots gonna pick up one
more
triple for him oh he gets the quad kill
are you kidding me
he gets every single one and keeps the
dream alive he might not win
every single clutch but he always forces
the other team to respect him
and that is what makes him a true clutch
god
taking the number one spot on our list
is the king of all clutches the man
they call the polite killer it's the
clutch minister himself
zipx only zips it'll be back to
backgrounds for g2
unless he can clutch it he's not for it
he's got the first shot and he got the
second as well
sid fix on inferno never ceases to amaze
that's so sick what was that shot zypix
has emerged as the undisputed king of
the clutch
but what makes him great is the variety
of ways he's
able to clutch he can win the aim duels
he can out strategize all five members
of the enemy team
he can even just get really damn lucky
oh my god oh my god oh my
zipix clutch minister's got a new
servant
unbelievable unbelievable he is the
clutch master
and that is ungodly i'm sorry it's gotta
go that way north
over the past few years no one has won
more clutches at big events than the
clutch minister
and we all know even when the odds are
stacked against him
zipyx always has a shot at victory his
own gun i think blocked the vision and
now sippix knows that they're working it
one above oh he's the lamb and it's the
slaughter because
all right well folks that's our list now
we're counting on you to come in the
clutch
right now and head over to twitch.tv
slash the score esports
be sure to follow the channel so you
never miss a stream
go on do it don't make us kick you
no he's no he's no he's at twitch.tv no
twitch.tv he went to youtube he went he
what happened to purple dude [ __ ]
went to mix dude
all right kick purple kick purple [ __ ]
it i'm done i'm done i'd rather have the
bot give me the bot
[ __ ] this